over the last century archaeologists in
China uncovered tens of thousands of
ancient Oracle bones which are the bones
of animals that carry some kind of
inscription the discoveries proved that
during the Shang Dynasty in ancient
China humans and animals were often
sacrificed in order to change the
weather one inscription on an oracle
bone red simply should a man be burnt at
the stakes Will Rain follow most of
these victims anthropologists noted were
slaves prisoners of War Beggars cripples
the Chinese believe that by killing off
these undesirables they'd cause it to
rain and in that sense the ancient
Chinese had a lot in common with many
other ancient cultures including the
Aztecs who fought Wars to secure new
victims for their human sacrifices and
those sacrifices included the ritual
killing of children on top of a mountain
or a pyramid to honor talalak their God
of rainfall
thousands of years later we have
inventions like meteorology and the
internet so you might think that ritual
sacrifices would have stopped but in
many parts of the world they've
persisted in 2007 for example Nepal's
state-run Airline was having a lot of
issues with one of their Boeing aircraft
and their solution at the time was to
sacrifice two goats in front of the
plane to appease the sky God and ensure
that the plane had safe passage
Executives were thrilled when the plane
managed to take off and land so I guess
it worked at the time the story was
mostly met with Amusement in this
country it was Unthinkable for anything
like that to happen here we thought sure
we have no room to make fun of them I
mean they might sacrifice a goat outside
of the plane but we allow people to
bring goats and other animals onto the
plains as emotional support animals as a
passenger I would prefer the sacrifice
strategy personally but at any rate
people clicked on the story for Nepal uh
maybe learned something you know about
Customs there had a good chuckle and
then went about their day
in retrospect that was a mistake because
as it turns out we were never that far
away from hearing our own politicians
claimed that they too have the power to
change the weather with their own
offerings to the sky God
somehow that line has officially been
crossed in this country and recently a
couple days ago Hillary Clinton posted a
tweet blaming Donald Trump's supporters
for the fact that the temperature has
gone up this summer
here it is quote hot enough for you
think of Mega Republican or better yet
vote them out of office
now you might recall that Maga
Republicans is an epithet that appeared
out of nowhere about a year ago when
Democratic party Consultants made it up
and already these Maga Republicans are
affecting the weather simply by existing
how are they doing that
one of the articles that Hillary Clinton
cites in her tweet was published in
Forbes and the piece reported that quote
July 4th was Earth's hottest day in over
000 years
now that's that's quite a claim since
we've only been able to track
temperatures for the past 140 years
according to NASA quote there are too
few Data before 1880 for scientists to
estimate average temperatures for the
entire planet that's what NASA says
and even for the past 140 years it seems
highly dubious to assume that the
records are accurate enough to
confidently declare that we experience
the hottest day in a century uh really a
century and a half this month
does anyone think that we actually have
a precisely accurate idea of what the
temperature was everywhere on the planet
on say I don't know August 11 1893
much less do we have do we know the
global temperature on August 11 1893 BC
so suffice it to say the Forbes piece is
not especially strong evidence to
support the idea that Trump voters are
somehow making it hot during the summer
so they have not even come close to
proving that we've had the hottest day
in 140 years much less a hundred
thousand hundred thousand years
um and so they they also have not proven
that uh that this weather is being
caused by Maga Republicans so there are
two things that need to be proved here
and they have done none of that
so let's take stock of what's Happening
this is kind of thing we often laugh
about and then just kind of move on from
but we should really spend some time
thinking about this
one of the most prominent Democrats in
the country
a former Secretary of State
former presidential candidate
just sincerely blamed her political
opponents for making it hot outside and
she did it on the basis of no evidence
whatsoever in fact she lied about what
little evidence she did present
now on some level we're used to the
climate change hysteria and the constant
claims of the world is ending so this
might not seem like anything new
but what makes this so especially insane
is that she's claiming that not only
does human activity change the weather
but that a relatively small group of
humans can bring about substantial
changes in the weather in the span of
just a few years
so this is not just
uh human activity has caused global
temperatures to rise by two degrees at
150 years or whatever you know this is
we're having a devastating Heat Wave
because of what my political opponents
did last Tuesday
we are in full-on primitive Superstition
territory here blaming your enemies for
a heat wave is the kind of thing that
you'd expect to hear from a a tribal
Chieftain and a loin cloth in the Amazon
somewhere
though I think even most of them are too
advanced at this point to believe in
that sort of thing
but that's the level of science that
senior Democrats are now pushing
what comes next in every other culture
that's gone down this path ritual
sacrifices what comes next Hillary
Clinton's already identified the problem
it's predominantly middle class
Americans who voted the wrong way in the
last election
they held too many cookouts they drove
trucks that were too big
therefore they're making it hot outside
and they need to pay
that's what she believes
how long before Hillary suggests
building a giant pyramid and cutting the
heart out of a middle-aged white guy in
a red hat in order to appease Mother
Mother Earth
or maybe just for fun
what's really alarming is that it's not
just Hillary Clinton who thinks this way
the rest of the party and the media has
been building to this conclusion for a
long time
they're not just blaming human activity
for the weather they're blaming very
recent and isolated human activity for
the weather
this kind of thinking took off sometime
around 2018 when the climate Institute
warned that people are changing the
weather currently actively just by
running their air conditioning units
the analysts determined that quote using
and producing air conditioning equipment
exacerbates climate change and they
propose that in lieu of using air
conditioning
you know people wear short sleeves and
rely on blinds and curtains more often
otherwise they said the climate will
change
and of course the climate did change
because climates always change because
that's what climates do
the same year the Washington Post ran an
op-ed entitled another hurricane is
about to batter our Coast Trump is
complicit
complicit in a hurricane
which is which is like accusing someone
of being complicit in a solar eclipse
so it took just a year after he came
into office for the Washington Post to
blame Trump for bad weather
then two months before the last
presidential election as wildfires
spread across California Joe Biden
endorsed that position as totally
deranged as it is
uh watch
the defense department reported that
climate change is a direct threat to
more than two-thirds of the military's
operationally critical installations
that's what the military warned him
and this could well be
this wall could be a conservative
estimate
Donald Trump
climate denial
may not have caused these fires and
record floods and record hurricanes but
if he gets a second term
these hellish events will continue to
become more common more devastating and
more deadly
if Trump gets a second term Biden said
then quote these hellish events will
continue to become more common more
devastating and more deadly in other
words we'll have more hurricanes
wildfires and floods and they'll be more
dangerous if Donald Trump is in office
for four years instead of Joe Biden
that's what he's saying and that was Joe
Biden in 2020 has anyone followed up
with him on that pledge now that he's
been in office for several years
has he declared victory over bad weather
remember he promised to cure cancer
I think cancer is still around last I
checked uh bad weather we're still still
having bad weather in fact he and his
allies like Hillary Clinton are actually
telling us that the weather has only
gotten worse
that's what they are telling us
he promised in 2020 that if Trump is not
voted into office then the weather will
get better it's going to get worse if
Trump is voted into office
which would lead us to believe that if
he's not the weather will get better now
they're telling us that the weather is
only getting worse
which means I guess we can blame Joe
Biden for that every Wildfire every
hurricane is Joe Biden's fault that's
the precedent they've set
Grand Canyon University is an affordable
private Christian University located in
beautiful Phoenix Arizona praise for its
culture of community giving and impact
Grand Canyon University integrates the
free market system into their education
welcoming Christian worldview
perspectives into over 320 academic
programs with more than 260 of those
programs online Grand Canyon
University's online programs are
designed to make earning your degree
easy and accessible no matter your age
or stage in life so why wait if you're
ready to take your education to the next
level find your purpose at Grand Canyon
University visit gcu.edu that's
gcu.edu as many of you know I wasn't
super thrilled when my family got a dog
but they're obsessed with the thing
which is why despite my own distaste for
The Mangy Beast I love making my family
happy part of doing that is keeping this
freeloader as healthy as possible which
is why I give my dog rough greens Dr
Dennis black the founder of rough greens
is focused on improving the health of
every dog in America little did I know
before I got rough greens dog food is
dead food everybody knows that nutrition
isn't Brown it's green but rough green
boost your dog's food back to life rough
grains is a supplement that contains all
the necessary vitamins minerals
probiotics Mega oils digestive enzymes
and antioxidants that your dog needs you
don't have to go out and buy new dog
food you just sprinkle rough grains on
their food every day dog owners
everywhere are raving about rough grains
it supports healthy joints improve bad
breath Boost energy levels and so much
more we are we are what we eat and that
goes for our dogs too Dr dense black is
so confident rough greens will improve
your dog's health he's offering my
listeners a free jump start trial bag so
your dog can try it a free jumpstart
trial bag can be at your door in just a
few business days go to
freeruffgreens.com Walsh or call 844
rough 700 that's free
r-u-f-fgreens.com Walsh or call 844
rough 700 today
oh no now they say well the only way to
keep the weather from continuing to get
worse is to keep voting for them
this is the scam and of course none of
it is remotely true here's the data on
global annual deaths from natural
disasters including wildfires volcanoes
extreme temperatures droughts
earthquakes floods it covers the 1990s
all the way to the 2010s and if you look
at a chart you can notice how how things
are much safer now
by every metric in fact but you never
hear about this
instead you're told that natural
disasters are getting more common and
more deadly
currently they're reporting that the
fires in Canada are historic
they said the same thing about the
California fires a few years ago in fact
every time there's a wildfire now it
seems like it's historic this has never
happened before the world has never seen
anything like this
the truth is that wildfires used to be
an order of magnitude worse than they
are now
ever hear about the the great Midwest
wildfires of 1871 probably not
somehow it's never mentioned and that's
strange because according to the
National Weather Service it was the
deadliest series of wildfires in
American history
those fires killed thousands of people
destroyed millions of Acres
how did that happen
how did it happen more than a century
before the rise of the Maga Republicans
who are causing all of this
our Mega Republicans able to control the
weather in the past two
how far does their sorcery reach
I guess we'll have to ask Hillary
Clinton about that
but let's be charitable for a second
let's assume for the sake of argument
that none of these outlets and
politicians are lying let's pretend that
we are in a climate emergency and
everybody's about to burn up and die
okay let's just pretend that for a
moment well
if that's the case you'd think Hillary
Clinton would be tweeting non-stop about
China you'd think that Joe Biden would
be imposing sanctions
China's carbon emissions are more than
double Americans in fact China emits
more carbon than every developed Nation
on the planet combined
have they done anything to curb these
emissions that are killing everybody
I mean this is an act of War if carbon
emissions are causing wildfires and
hurricanes in the United States then
this is like an act of War by China
against the United States
so what is Joe Biden doing about it
I mean China is building the equivalent
of two large coal plants every week
this year China's carbon emissions have
already set a new record
but Hillary Clinton and Joe Biden don't
seem concerned instead they're demanding
that you give up your gas stove and vote
for them or else
they leave China alone in the meantime
now we've seen this before remember when
uh the left went on a campaign against
plastic straws a few years ago and they
were warning that our plastic straws are
polluting the ocean and killing the sea
turtles and that's the whole reason why
when you go somewhere now you get those
flimsy paper straws that dissolve in
your soda the moment you try to use them
well that's a sacrifice we got to make
to keep the sea turtles healthy well
what they refuse to mention is that many
Asian countries dump their trash
directly into their Rivers sending
millions of tons of garbage straws
included
floating out into the ocean in a giant
conveyor belt-like system every year
now we're seeing the same pattern play
out with carbon emissions
except in this case our leaders our
leaders are the ones who enabled China's
rise of the as the world's largest
polluter 20 years ago Bill Clinton
approved the U.S China trade agreement
and China's entrance into the World
Trade Organization he said that more
trade with China would benefit Americans
he promised that it would not crush the
U.S manufacturing sector quite the
opposite quote will be able to export
products without exporting jobs he
promised
and how has that worked out exactly
but they refuse to take any
responsibility for their role in
creating the single greatest polluter on
the planet
someone who by their logic and by their
argument is is
killing the planet and all of us
the clintons and the rest of their party
have to have displayed no
self-reflection or regret whatsoever
about what they did that's because they
don't regret it
they don't care about carbon emissions
and you know what they don't really
think that Maga Republicans whoever
those are are actively making it hot in
the summer
at least the leftists in charge don't
buy that stuff
it's all fake
okay they care about power
to the point that Hillary Clinton is now
babbling like an Aztec shaman
except the Aztec Shaman would at least
acknowledge
is practicing religion not science
we are ruled by people who can't tell
the difference if you'd like to see what
else I have to say you can access my
full show by going to dailywire.com or
by going to the Matt wall Show Twitter
page hope to see you there Godspeed